No, a graph is a data
structure.
That has edges.
to
multiple vertices a special
type of graph is a tree
it's a special type of graph in which
the edges
are not circular they do not.
Go back to the same vertex again.
So it's very one way.
You can see here at the in this particular.
graph
at introducing some terminology we call this
a
Typically in Tree in trees we
call that we call these vertices nodes, but again
the word is interchangeable. So we have these nodes.
And then we have these sub branches. We have the branch on
the left and the branch on the right.
and we call the
edges
at the end of the tree. This is like a tree turned
upside down right where the roots of the tree are
at the top and the leaves are at
the bottom. So if you can imagine a tree that has turned upright.
so if we have a node that does not Branch off to
any other node, we call those leaves right because
it's analogous to a tree right?
It turns out.
Trees are very good for searching for
values very quickly.
Let me show you an example of a binary tree.
Now here's a binary tree a
pectoral.
better pectoral representation of it and if you
haven't seen one take a moment to
see why it's ordered the way it is.
So this is a sequence of
numbers
from 1 to 21
some of the numbers are missing.
but the binding tree is
arranged and really its purpose is to search
for
values very quickly efficiently
when the position of that particularly value
is unknown.
So if you see here the smallest number in
this.
a set of
numbers is one.
Which is at the very far left and if you look at the very far, right
you will see that it is the largest value of
this collection.
And then if you look at the root node or
the root vertex, if you like we have the number
10.
Which is the number between 1 and 21?
If we have an array.
Which is a linear.
a collection of numbers
then searching that list for a
particular number can take
we say
linear time
if you remember earlier, I mentioned something called time complexity.
It's time complexity.
worst case and in worst case we did not
work case with all of an
with Big O
it will be in.
What does that mean? It means that if you have a list with
a 100 values
And let's see you're searching for the number 100. Let's say
have a list of numbers going from 1 to 100 and you
do not know for some reason you do not know where the
number 100 is.
If you want to find that number you have to start counting from left.
all the way to the right
and it's called and it's all of n because
the number of times that you have to search for the
value is
equivalent to the number of elements you have in the
list. So if you have a hundred values and you're looking for particular value
worst case scenario will be at the end of the list. So you have to go to
the entire list to find what you're looking for.
Now, of course you could be lucky and it appears somewhere in the beginning or maybe in the
middle.
But when we calculate the time complexity of an algorithm we
want to count or we want to take you
to count the worst case now. We want to be prepared for the worst possible
scenario.
Now with an array
The problem can get exasperated.
And the time complexity can be greater.
As the data structure gets bigger. So if you have a million
values or 10 million values worst case
now, you have to search through the 10 to the entire collection of
talent million values to find what you're
looking for. So it's not efficient.
Arrays are not efficient if for searching for
things.
When the position of that thing is not no.
enter the binary tree
So you see here we have like I said a range
of values from 1 to 21.
And at the root we have the number 10. So say you're
looking for the number 17.
The way you would search for the number 17 in an array is
to start counting from laughter, right?
Whereas in an array, you don't do that.
In a binary trimmer to say you don't
do that in a binary tree you go through root note and you ask yourself this
oh, this is what the algorithm will do.
Is the number 17 less than or greater
than 10?
Well, that's greater than 10 and because it's greater
than 10. We can eliminate the entire left Branch
altogether, so we don't even have to look at this part.
Now then we turn to the right branch.
with node 19 and we ask
Is 17 less than or greater than
19? It's less than
and so we now this is this is a
very shallow trees so it will take
I mean we have reached our
matching element
But I hope you I get the idea we were able to have.
the search time
using this data structure
now the time complexity of the binary
tree this binary the binary
tree data structure.
And in terms of Big O in terms of the worst case scenario is
log base 2 of n
y log base 2 event because you are repeatedly having
each branch.
So it's even better than having the search time.
So if you want to search for values whose
positions are not known this is the data
structure you want to go with now, like I said, this is one variant
of a graph data structure.
So trees are variations of Greeks of graph.
Excuse me.
databases Implement something called the
B3
databases have to be be able to contain large
volumes of data.
But also make it.
They also have to be very quick in finding
it particular value in the large collection. So the
the Implement something called a b tree if you want to learn more
about those, like I said look in the look at the video description.
to
learn more about graph data structures
and graphs in general